hello and welcome to gamespot plays Grim
Fandango remastered a classic that I am
embarrassed to say I've never actually
played oh my god yeah Jeremy Jane i know
i don't know i'm sitting here with my
sweet grim fandango shirt on reppin it
hard that you wore by accident yeah of
course bags and I'm repping the telus
principles another game that I have not
played a little bit just not the whole
thing great anyway let's jump into this
game that is nothing at all about I want
to tell you all about this bad boy this
came out in 1998 originally it was
gamespot's a game of the year on pc back
then really and this is the remastered
edition which double fighters put ask
this originally made by lucas but then
mr. tim schafer was involved in it and
we're about one puzzle in at this stage
oh look at this yes look at this this is
the land of the living yeah I'm thing as
Manny calavera who is a travel agent for
the Department of death and in keeping
with Mexican and afterlife traditions
right and once you die you have to like
travel the via benign underworlds or
whatever it okay get to the promised to
get to the after the real after like the
good base and and the better you are the
faster you can travel so many here in
his lovely Grim Reaper garb I was gonna
say usually wears a suit he's actually
still to the moment as well you'll see
later and he he sells packages to people
and so if you're really good you get to
go on the number nine train all right
maybe you don't get that you get a boat
which is pretty fast but if you've been
bad you've to walk it so he's like a
grim reaper travel agent hybrid exactly
salespeople packages to a better part of
the afterlife yes and we've just turned
off in the land of living here which I
think this is the only time you ever
hear this is arif we have to hide this
person open to 2m see if they're if
they're goody and when he wants a goodie
what is this is he gets Commission
writhing beast on the ground will open
in a second but first of all I'll mess
with these people ok oh oh what is this
ms paint horror she'll go in the living
is technically against the rules but we
all do it oh I do it daily if I scare
them to death then they'll become a
customer but I'll get nailed with a
conflict of interest rapper it's
hilarious they said this is basically a
lot of people say it was like the the
last great adventure game yeah it's me
dead
I'll see you soon so can they can they
see him or is it sort of like he can
like interact with them ghost-like like
yeah this is like that they can't really
see him like you can see these scream
bleep hamburger cows are a whole other
Bureau not to mention the lettuce this
is so good I'm a profession all right so
we better get is the inventory system
okay so I noticed right away that
there's no HUD in this game at all yes
there's not in fact money there's no one
of the problems of adventure games back
in the day was that you basically just
scroll your mouse over everything and
see what was interactive right and this
you basically go by Maddie's hair all
right so he looks at singles you can
interact with exactly oh that's that's
intuitive so he's really hoping that
whoever's in this bag is a real good
person will make skelton nice bathroom
to the better the person the better deal
he can seldom so a good person he can
set them on a ticket to the number nine
okay it's like commission off of it as
well and if you're real piece of [ __ ]
you get stuck in the underworld forever
are you have to walk it up oh you can
walk it so you want something cheap
where you can get some rest I could make
this go a little faster that's our
friend girl office this is a bad five
minutes into the game or 30 minutes
depending on if you've ever really hit
this before alright so it's only after
the first puzzler wat not so this isn't
very spoilery at all okay cool Gladys is
wonderful mr. Martinez and you'll be
safely padded by the foam created when
there's two chemicals mix well second
thought I want to upgrade my package oh
my god hurry Bruno would you didn't
qualify for anything better but here
poor Bruno complimentary mug first day
at the end of your life this guy
obviously wasn't very good and sadly is
gonna get packed a pair might his way to
the light underworld or whatever he's is
crazy probably this guy
lazy sickle waivers like this jolly boy
working for me so what Manny is done we
don't really know but he is paying off
whatever he's done in the previous life
I by working at this okay traveler he's
eventually trying to get there as well
okay so is that sort of the arc of this
game is that he's trying to get to the
better afterlife himself and he thinks
enough and he thinks that this might be
something a little fishy going on with
his business because there's certain
people who seem to not be getting their
tickets on the number nine okay and he's
also not really sure why he's had to
work in servitude in the ingrained in
the underworld does it work and the game
takes place over a number of years
actually yeah you traveling with Maddie
kind of threw his journey to redemption
okay it's fitting for like a film noir
influence thing to that he's like a
flawed protagonist that he did like work
his way through his morality play it
looks cool theme wise this is a super
unique it ya know I'm super into this
already this is cool like it's gonna fly
in here tied to a brick it's time to
take one so he wants to get a good case
because he's sick of taking all these
copies right right and the certain
people in this business who seem to be
getting way better cases and so one of
the things in this game that's that's
new is the graphic so this is what it
originally looked like oh you can switch
back and forth again click the right
again that's tiny go at so the
backgrounds are pretty much all the same
but basically the lighting model as you
can see for instance here and all the
models are the lighting is way better
although I read before we did this that
the lighting the original used the same
software that they were using for like
Lucasfilm and industrial film magic or
whatever it's called Lucasfilm people to
use the same software as the CG effects
oh yeah and you missed a great client
Domino came back from there with a nun
equally I got a tiny little man with a
mean temper and no Commission at least
you don't work for one so I'm gonna try
and hit the next puzzle pretty quickly
because they think about this game is
that you spend a lot of time walking
back and forth and try to figure out
exactly what to do right and but if you
played this game before it's a lot a lot
easier so yeah if I was driving here
this would be a let's play in which we
made about two minutes of progress so I
there's a pack of cards you see at this
table I picked it up at the start of the
game again only about 10 minutes ago or
an hour ago depending on a few played
this game before and what I want to do
is I want to try in them get a better
case for money
this dude in here this jerk all the
dominoes how is he sweating out of his
bones that's a good point and he gets
all the good jobs and many thinks it
might be a problem with the mailing
system the tube system in this case
that's a that's not allowing him to get
all the best cases that is some deep
running corruption so let's go run down
and interact with some with some
people's so when this game came out was
this because i know now this is like a
classic everyone knows this is a good
game but when this came out was it
generally regarded as like like a step
forward or like a great game in terms of
mechanics jeffrey was it was one of the
first sort of 3d adventure games you
know Simon max went that way as well
eventually but like you know especially
for lupus who are making monkey on the
walk nas yeah and no David tentacle that
sort of stuff this is a new venture for
them and it was also around the time
that like adventure games were kind of
having a hard time so people thought
that this might breathe actually you
know new life into into the genre as it
happens it didn't it sold well but not
enough to justify the cost from Lucas
eventually didn't yeah it sort of did
the opposite right where it sort of
prompted Lucas to be like we put a lot
of money into this game that's sold
decently like maybe we should sort of go
back to making a thousand Star Wars yeah
I wonder and then they promptly did you
know that room there was the male tube
system so I want to get in there and I
want to mess with it obviously what I'm
gonna do is talk to this balloon man
naturally put in a pinch I'm practice I
hate this job I can I see what ring in
your neck what is the jack nicholson
mariachi surprising just we have one of
them
yeah yeah yeahs twist this all right i
love this particular look at the
original the crazy oh wow so loving
that's got your cat but you can't do it
cat shows what you know buddy i can do
anything i can do birds and fib Ian's
famous poets william butler yeats now
bears Robert Frost Oh trying to stump me
a this guy doesn't mean Robert Frost oh
here he goes I feel like he's got a pipe
and everything that is pretty good it
was better than I expected my finest
work I think the Robert Frost GOG is
gonna go down real good in a 2015 yeah
what actually want it's so timely but
actually want is a dead worm okay so I
want that's easy you could ask for
another robber for us you're like 90 a
question I feel it needs to feel
satisfied there's no limit on these ones
actually and it turns out I do actually
want more of those ever so like this is
something you would not know unless you
had ever played this game before or like
I think most people should play this
game you were playing it with gamefaqs
open on your phone because like that's
the weird thing about this is like even
the first time i play this i remember
having to go to the guide spurt before
like this world is so strange and
idiosyncratic and like unique but like
it's not like monkey island where you
can use a sort of a degree of you know I
know certain things about pirate culture
so I'll use that to my advantage like
right for me it's at least going off by
Carmen I think you know for anyone like
Noir and you know it was a deal it's
that like this more tests yeah it's like
the Mesoamerican afterlife traditions
like it sits heavily as tech-based I
guess mmm like that's it's not exactly
like you can pull much from these ya
what I'm gonna do is that packing fluid
that I got before I'm gonna fill one of
them up with that one obviously gonna
take other diver I would never figure
this out I would be I would have thought
that that guy making balloon animals was
just like a funny side guy don't like a
Robert Frost balloon but like the number
one rule of every adventure game is that
nobody is ever there for ya no reason
like you're always there for a reason
it's like Chekhov's gun in theater where
like if you see a gun it's gonna go off
before the end of the play yeah like
it's like
if you see a guy with a balloon animal
you probably gonna use it to like open a
door and if you frost and if you see a
pack of cards on a whole bunch solitaire
on the computer Manny oh thanks any
welcome state use it as well there you
go Manny what are you doing just marking
cards honey oh that's not wrong it's
capable hey you see ya you see my Robert
Frost and one other thing to mention is
see the thing up in the corner l1 yeah
so this was the first game has developer
commentary are you [ __ ] me so it's
pretty great as well so it's a bunch of
people from Lucas including tim schafer
artists and designers everything that's
insane don't you probably you move from
room to room and it turns off but it's
pretty good especially for like someone
like me who's played this game before
like it's a real it's like another
excuse to ya go through it and enjoy it
so for sure you're not just like going
through the motions you're actually like
learning more about when your favorite
games exactly that's really cool that's
a nice feature here's the mail system oh
this is like some wallace and gromit ass
animation so it's already time to go
wrong but i think if i add another one
of those the other compound into this
we'll see what happens then yeah Nessus
go ahead i love it looks like an that's
pretty graphic yep so it all goes to 0
just a really inefficient mail system it
couldn't they just have indeed they pay
minimum wage down there just like
delivering the mail apparently back in
like the the 40s and 50s New York was
like covered in like this tube system
yeah like I don't like yeah dude if you
go into old hotels especially in the
East Coast they're like they're really
tall ones in Boston in New York there's
just these tubes that like you'll give
em a 24th floor it'll be like really to
the mailroom and it has like it's like a
huge hydraulic tube thing this guy's
fixing it and I know because I played
this game a million times that there's
actually a little latch here any luck
seemed look down yeah
and you really deserve an open door
strange yet symbolic these compelling so
now I want to talk to this guy obviously
is the server down is the surfer hair
this is their idea of a joke this guy is
a so there's often them these kind of
demons who were also living in the
afterlife okay even a very specific job
to do I was gonna say like this guy
clearly does not look like a department
human no the server's down is that it
server is not down it's never down not
just temporarily unavailable while I'm
doing classic idea right yeah apparently
that's a line from one of the lucasarts
IT guys okay he used to always say that
oh that's genius yeah so I'm gonna say
probably hour until no one's around it
which ever comes from think I got us i
think i don't need to actually do
anything on this i think i just got to
interact with them and then get out of
here i believe and then
that butt crack sweet sweet pointy
triangle by 20 oh yeah it's got such a
like monkey build like little tiny
biceps and giant worms you try to blow
this joint sky I almost got set on fire
ezhu a magnesium come by a fire
extinguisher I wonder if that will I
wonder if later Kim victory item Danny I
wonder if you might have one in your
jacket so I'm gonna get out of here now
let's just do do is work I believe once
i get out of here he leaves lock him in
pixel a car dash which end starts
machine up Oh like a great saying I also
like how its DoD on the back of
everyone's cherish day of the dead yeah
it's also Donnie O'Dwyer oh yeah how
about that door didn't close yeah so the
first time you do this yeah like then
you have to figure out how so if you do
that you don't do the door latched you
if you do this whole segment again you
sure do Jeremy oh boy im operative game
so like that's in a way that like you
know 1998 yeah just a little bit 20 you
know adventure games now or kind of a
weird things well wonder how many people
are going to be playing this game and
ripping their hair out yeah are like
who's gonna play this game without
nostalgic value you know yeah no I mean
I'll probably play this game honestly a
suit was pretty great if I didn't do the
card as well that wouldn't the fish
right field
died of chicken pox Nemec dead yadda
yadda ya a positive attributes the
volunteer time reading stories to dying
children all right so she's got garlic
horn that's really good and yep you read
me say this go to meijer I think you're
the one for me I really like the weird
like Mexican soap opera hi it's so
bizarre it's pretty gross this is one of
the strangest feels to a game plot us a
demon yes says he looks like a Dean hey
I love how they haven't really changed
his marble much at all yes that just
looks like a kind of a piece of crap so
compressed to it's like made of squares
and this basically starts off the sort
of main story thread of grim fandango
and let's hear your old friend Gladys
here's dr hon studio in ham dry and
Gladys on his car end up being a
recurring theme in this game widows dia
and here's met Jay you're not the nurse
a femme fatale no you're not here to
give me my medication no but I am here
to ease your pain guess they couldn't
save Mia no but there's still a chance
you could save me and that's a Grim
Fandango remastered it's a really
wonderful it's like one of the biggest
touch points in adventure game history
unlike games like monkey island it has a
sort of a soul to us uh you know
ironically I guess yeah and it's it's
touching in ways that those games
weren't but it's also probably one of
the funniest adventure games ever to
come out so it said on the PlayStation 4
PlayStation Vita on pc mac and linux as
well and i think if you're a fan of the
game in the past I could definitely
recommend playing it I'm not so sure if
you've never played it before but if
going to a game faq isn't like a big
deal for you then yeah absolutely check
it yeah I'm definitely intrigued alright
so that's gamespot play is grim fandango
let us know what you think in the
comments below and stay tuned for more
games hot place